[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ:
OK, so last time, we
were talking about sequences,
and I introduced the notion
of a limit of a sequence.
So we say that x n converges to
x if for all epsilon positive
there exists an M,
a natural number,
such that for all little n
bigger than or equal to capital
M we have x sub n minus
x is less than epsilon.
So what this definition
says is that given
any little bit of tolerance,
as long as I go far enough
out in the sequence,
the entries are getting
within that tolerance to x.
And when x then
converges to x, we'll
write x is equal to the limit as
n goes to infinity of x sub n,
or using this notation,
x sub n arrow x.
And so I've said
before that if you ever
have a reasonably complicated
or interesting definition,
you should try to come up
with examples and negate it.
So the end of last time,
we saw a few examples of--
at least one example of--
a convergent sequence.
Let's negate this definition
because then we'll
also come up with an
example of a sequence which
does not converge.
And so the negation
of this definition
is that x n does
not converge to x.
What does this mean?
So this is the
actual negation part.
If there exists an
epsilon positive-- so
whenever we negate a "for all,"
it becomes "there exists,"
and whenever we negate
a "there exists,"
it becomes a "for all."
So there exists some bad
epsilon 0 positive such
that for all natural numbers
N, there exists an n bigger
than or equal to M
such that x n minus
x is bigger than or equal to
this bad epsilon 0 in distance.
So we have a picture that
goes along with convergence.
We can have a picture that
goes along with a sequence not
converging to x.
So this means if I go out
within this bad epsilon 0,
and if I go arbitrarily
out in the sequence,
I can always find an
element x sub n which
is not in that interval.
And we use this negation
to prove a certain sequence
does not converge to x.
But let's go back
do another example
of a sequence which
does converge, so--
equals 0.
So again, how does the proof go?
You have to verify the
definition of the limit.
I mean, there's nothing else
that we have to use right now.
So let epsilon be positive.
And now, off to
the side over here,
I'm going to do a
little bit of work
to show you how
exactly in practice one
would find such a capital M
or choose a capital M to get
that 1 over n squared plus
30n plus 1 would be less
than epsilon for n bigger
than or equal to capital M.
So typically how this works
is, unlike in calculus
where you have some inequality
that you want to get
and then you solve for
n, in analysis what's
great is that you can
replace that thing
you want to make small
by something simpler,
and then solve that inequality.
What do I mean?
So what I want to do,
I want to find M so
that if n it is bigger
than or equal to M, then--
so I'm saying the limit is
0, so I want to show 1 over n
squared plus 30n plus
1 is less than epsilon.
Now, I could try to solve
this inequality for n,
but this is a quadratic function
and imagine I put 20 there,
so I can't exactly solve
exactly for n to guarantee this.
But what's great about
analysis is that I
don't have to work that hard.
I could start with
this thing which
I want to bound by epsilon,
replace it by something bigger,
and then find capital
M so that that bigger
thing is less than epsilon.
So what do I mean?
So let's start with this thing--
1 over n squared
plus 30n plus 1.
So this one is only
making things bigger.
I'm going to do
this very slowly.
So this is less than
or equal to this
because for this, I've just
added 1 to the denominator.
And 1 over n squared plus 30n--
this certainly looks
a little bit simpler
to solve for n
less than epsilon.
But I can make it even simpler
by dropping the n squared,
because n squared is
positive, so that's
only making the bottom bigger.
So I've 1 over 30n,
and this is certainly
less than or equal to 1 over n.
So what does this
computation show?
This shows that if 1 over
n is less than epsilon,
then this implies that 1 over
n squared plus 30n plus 1 is
less than epsilon.
If this thing is
less than epsilon,
then by this string
of inequalities,
this thing will be
less than epsilon.
So we choose capital
M so that we get this.
Now, when we actually
write the proof,
it'll look something like this.
But the actual
style of the proof
is a little bit different.
And if you didn't see
this, it would just
seem like I pulled this
capital M out of nowhere,
but this is the thinking
that goes behind it.
So let epsilon be positive.
Now I'll tell you how to
choose capital M. Choose
M a natural number so
that-- so we want it
for all n bigger than or
equal to capital M, 1 over n
is less than epsilon.
So this will
certainly be true if n
is bigger than or
equal to capital M
so that 1 over capital
M is less than epsilon.
And the reason we
can choose capital
M like this-- again,
where is this coming from?
It's coming from the Archimedean
property of the real numbers.
So we've chosen
capital M. Now we
need to show that
this capital M works.
Then for all n bigger than
or equal to capital M,
if I look at 1 over n
squared plus 30n plus 1
minus 0, my proposed
limit, this is equal to 1
over n squared plus 1.
And this is less
than or equal to,
if I drop n squared
and 1, 30n, which
is less than or equal to 1
over n, which is less than
or equal to 1 over capital M,
which is less than epsilon.
So something of a non-example--
let's show that the sequence
minus 1 to the n DNC
does not converge--
not Democratic
National Committee--
does not converge.
So this is just a
sequence minus 1,
1, minus 1, 1,
minus 1, and so on.
So we have to show
it does not converge,
meaning for every
x in R, we'll show
that x n does not converge
to x using the negation
of the definition--
so proof.
Let x be in R. And what
do we want to show?
Minus 1 to the n-th
does not converge to x.
And we'll use this definition.
So this definition means we
need to find a bad epsilon 0.
And here's the kind of thinking
that goes along with this--
there's 1, there's minus 1.
This sequence just keeps
alternating, so intuitively
there's no way that every
element of the sequence
can be getting--
or every entry in the
sequence can be getting--
close to some single x.
So what's the idea?
The idea is that the distance
between these two guys
is always 2.
So somehow, the distance
between every entry,
or basically, some entry
has to be within distance--
if this is within distance
1, say, to a given x,
then this will be greater than
or equal to 1 in distance to x.
So you can imagine
x is over here.
Minus 1 is within
distance 1 to x,
but then 1 would be greater
than distance 1 to x.
So our bad epsilon 0 was
going to be 1, as we'll see.
Let epsilon 0 equals 1.
That's our bad epsilon.
So now we have to
show for all capital
M in the natural numbers,
there exists a little n
bigger than or
equal to capital M
so that we have that inequality.
So let M be a natural number.
Then what do we see?
So then it says, they're
exists an n greater than
or equal to capital
M. And I will
show that n is, in fact,
either capital M or capital
M plus 1, then 2, which is
the distance between minus 1
to the M and minus
1 to the M plus 1 is
less than or equal to-- now
using the triangle inequality,
I add and subtract x and then
use the triangle inequality.
So I have the sum of two numbers
is bigger than or equal to 2.
And the only way that can happen
is if one of these numbers
is bigger than or equal to 1.
If both of these
numbers are less than 1,
then the sum is less than 2, and
I would have 2 is less than 2.
That's not possible.
So one of these numbers has to
be bigger than or equal to 1.
And therefore, I could
take n equal to capital M
if this is bigger
than or equal to 1,
or if this is bigger
I take little n to
be capital M plus 1.
So that's the end of that.
So that's good for
examples for now.
Let's prove a general theorem
about convergent sequences--
namely, that if I have a
convergent sequence, then
it's bounded.
And let me just give
you a quick reminder
about what being bounded
means for a sequence, i.e.,
there exists some number
such that for all n,
x n is less than or
equal to capital B. Now,
as beginning students of
math, what types of questions
should we start
asking ourselves?
So one of the types,
or a type of question
that we should ask when we
come across the theorem that
is a one-way street,
meaning if something
happens then something
else happens,
is does the converse hold?
Namely, if I assume x sub
n is a bounded sequence,
does this imply that
x n is convergent?
So if you ever hear the words,
"does the converse hold,"
that's what they mean.
Now, for this statement,
this is false.
If x n is bounded implies
x n is convergent,
that's false because we
have an example right
there of a bounded sequence.
This sequence here,
minus 1 to the n,
is bounded since the
sequence in absolute value
equals 1 for all n, so
we could take B equals 1.
So minus 1 to the n
is a bounded sequence,
which is not convergent.
So the converse does not hold.
So let's prove the theorem.
And let me draw a little
picture to go along
with it of what's going on.
So here is 0, let's imagine.
Let me make this picture
a little bit bigger
before I go into the proof.
So let x be the limit.
So this is not the proof yet.
This is just more discussion.
So if this x sub n
is converging to x,
then let's say I go
out distance 1 to x.
Then all of the x
sub n's eventually
have to land in this strip here.
So x sub n, n bigger than
or equal to some capital M.
So I know that they're all
within distance 1 to x.
So in absolute value,
they'd be bounded by,
let's say for this
picture, it'd be x plus 1.
But if this was
over there, capital,
it would be the absolute
value of x plus 1.
So that takes care of all x
sub n's with n bigger than
or equal to M. And then
there's only finitely many guys
to deal with.
Maybe there's a bigger one
out here, x sub n minus 1
to deal with, and that's
how we define our number,
is by the absolute
value of x plus 1
plus the absolute value
of these finitely many.
And then that would
be something that's
bigger than or equal to every
element in the sequence.
That's the picture
that goes with it.
How do we take that
picture to proof?
So suppose x n converges to
x-- that's our assumption,
and there exists a
natural number M such
that for all n bigger than
or equal to capital m, x sub
n minus x is within distance 1,
or x sub n is within distance 1
to x, then for all n bigger
than or equal to capital M,
if we look at the
absolute value of x sub n,
add and subtract x, and now
use the triangle inequality,
this is less than or equal
to absolute value of x sub
n minus x plus the absolute
value of x equals 1 plus x.
So for all entries in the
sequence past this point
capital M, they're bounded in
absolute value by 1 plus x.
That's just a number.
So then, we just have
to take care of the 1
up to capital M minus 1 guys.
We just have to
find a number bigger
than those guys and
this number, and we'll
have found a B.
So then let's take
B to be x sub 1 plus x
sub 2 plus x sub capital
M minus 1 plus this.
Then for all n a natural number,
the absolute value of x of n
is less than or equal
to B. Because if n
is less than capital M,
then its absolute value
is bounded by one of these.
Its absolute value is
equal to 1 over these,
and therefore, less than
or equal to one of these
plus some non-negative numbers.
And if n is bigger than
or equal to capital M,
then we have this
bound that we use.
And this number is
certainly less than
or equal to capital
B, again, because it's
this number plus a sum
of non-negative numbers.
Now in general, there's no
easily checkable criterion
for a sequence to converge.
All we can do is
verify the definition.
But there are some sequences
which you can easily
check or figure out
if they converge just
by telling if they're bounded.
Those are what are called
"monotone sequences."
So this is, in some
sense, the class
of sequences that
does kind of satisfy
the converse of that theorem
I stated a minute ago.
So sequence x sub n
is monotone increasing
if for all natural numbers
little n, x sub n is less than
or equal to x sub n plus 1.
So this means that
x sub 1 is less
than or equal to x sub 2 is
less than or equal to x to 3,
and so on.
Sequence is monotone
decreasing if we
have the other inequality.
So things are getting
smaller, so x sub n
is bigger than or equal
to x sub n plus 1.
And if we have a sequence
which is monotone increasing
or monotone decreasing--
so it's one or the other--
we say x n is
monotone or monotonic.
So it's simple enough to come
up with examples of sequences
which are monotone
increasing, monotone
decreasing, or neither.
So 1 over n--
this is just 1, 1/2, 1/3, 1/4--
this is monotone decreasing.
And if I take
minus the sequence,
then that reverses basically
all of the inequalities,
and I get a monotone
increasing one.
So then this is minus
1, minus 1/2, minus 1/3,
minus 1/4, monotone increasing.
And then something
that's not is-- we've
already come across that--
minus 1 to the n, and so on.
And so the theorem
about monotone sequences
is that there is a simpler
criterion than the definition
for determining when
they're convergent,
or if you like, they satisfy
the converse of this theorem up
here.
So a monotonic sequence
is convergent if and only
if it is bounded.
So we proved a minute ago
that convergent sequences
are bounded, so for monotonic
sequences, the converse holds.
So let's do the proof of this.
I'm going to do the proof for
monotone increasing sequences,
and as an exercise,
I'll leave it to you
to do the proof for monotone
decreasing sequences.
So suppose x sub n is a
monotone increasing sequence.
So there's two directions to
prove convergence if and only
if bounded.
So we have one
direction, meaning
convergence implies bounded.
This is just the
previous theorem,
where we proved that every
convergent sequence is bounded,
not just monotonic sequences.
So the meat is in proving
the converse direction.
And in fact, we'll be
able to pick out what
the limit is of this sequence.
So suppose x sub n is bounded.
Then if I look at
the set of entries--
so not the sequence but if
I look at the set of values
that this sequence takes-- so x
sub n is just a natural number,
this is now a subset
of the real numbers.
This is a bounded set, meaning
it's bounded above and below
because there exists some
capital B so that x sub
n is, in absolute
value, less than
or equal to capital B for all n.
So that means x sub n is
between B and minus B.
All right, so what's the picture
again that goes with this?
So we have these x sub n's,
x sub 1, x sub 2, x sub 3.
We know that they cannot
go past a certain B,
and they're steadily increasing,
but they can't keep strictly--
they can't increase
without bound.
Not only that, they're
bounded by some number
x, which I'll define to be
the supremum of this set.
And these guys are just
getting, in essence--
so this is a picture,
just me trying
to explain to you
what's going on.
If x is the sup of this
set of entries, then
what do I know about x sub n?
I mean x is that if I go a
little bit to the left of x--
so let me draw this again.
So let me back up a minute here.
So since this set is bounded
in R, it has a supremum in R.
And what I claim is that
this supremum is, in fact,
the limit of this sequence.
This is a supremum of a set.
I'm saying it's the
limit of the sequence.
So what's the thinking here?
So x is the supremum of
all the entries in x sub n,
so nothing's ever
going to be bigger
than some tolerance
x plus epsilon.
So we just need to worry about
what's to the left of it.
And we need to find
a capital number
M so that all the x sub
n's are in this interval
here, because we're trying
to show that the x sub
n's converge to x, the
supremum of this guy.
So let's walk through
this by this picture.
So x is the supremum.
Nothing's bigger than x,
so all of the x sub n's
are to the left
of x plus epsilon.
So now we just need to
worry about x minus epsilon.
Now, since x is the supremum
of this set, x minus epsilon
can't be an upper bound for
the set of entries of x sub n.
So that means there has to
exist some x sub M so that it's
bigger than x minus epsilon.
But now, this is where we
use the fact that this is
a monotone increasing sequence.
Because then, if n is bigger
than or equal to capital M,
then x sub n is strictly
to the right of x sub M,
or it's equal to x sub M
and still less than or equal
to x because x is the
supremum of all the entries.
So then, for n bigger than
or equal to capital M,
they all have to lie
in this interval.
And that's why the
sequence converges
to the supremum of this set.
So we're using,
in a crucial way,
the fact that this sequence
is monotonic increasing.
I'll prove this claim.
Let epsilon be positive.
Then since x minus
epsilon is not
an upper bound for
this set, x sub n,
there exists an
M0, natural number,
so that x sub n minus
epsilon is less than x
sub M0 is less
than or equal to x.
And we'll choose
M to be this M0.
Then for all n bigger
than or equal to M,
we have x sub n minus epsilon,
which is less than x sub M0.
And because n is bigger
than or equal to capital M,
and this is a monotone
increasing sequence,
x sub M0 is less than
or equal to x sub n.
And because x is a
supremum of the set
of all entries of
this sequence, this
is less than or equal to
x, which is less than x
plus epsilon.
Or to summarize--
so this should not
be x sub n, that should
be x minus epsilon.
Or x minus epsilon is less
than x sub n is less than x
plus epsilon.
And that's the same as showing
the absolute value of x sub
n minus x is less than epsilon.
Now, what's the change
for monotone decreasing
is that we'll be
able to identify
the limit of the
sequence as being
the imf, the
infimum of this set.
But I'll leave that
to you as an exercise.
So let's use this real quick to
prove the limit of a little bit
more interesting sequence
than 1 over this one,
which is reasonably
interesting, I guess.
But typically in math, we
just don't prove theorems
for the sake of
proving theorems.
Typically, there's some
concrete reason we do things.
There's some concrete
sequence we're
trying to prove converges,
or has a certain property,
or doesn't have a
certain property.
And so the basic one is if
you like a geometric sequence.
So if c is a positive
number between 0 and 1,
then we'll prove that
this sequence c to the n
is convergent and
it converges to 0.
And we'll prove if
c is bigger than 1,
then the sequence c
to the n is unbounded.
In particular, it
can't converge.
So let's go in reverse order.
Let's prove that if
c is bigger than 1,
then this thing is unbounded.
It doesn't require 1,
but it's shorter than 1,
and we can go ahead and do it.
And we'll use this
fact that we proved,
I think, in the first or
second lecture using induction.
So what does it mean to
show something is unbounded?
Again, we get to use
our negation skills.
It means that-- what
do we want to show--
for all B bigger
than or equal to 0,
there exists an n, a natural
number, so that c to the n
is bigger than B. Now, how
are we going to find this n?
This seems like a
complicated thing.
So let's replace it
by something simpler.
Again, this is analysis, which
means we get to use our wits,
and try to replace complicated
things by simpler things,
and work with the
simpler things.
So let me do a little bit of--
again, this is off
to the side, how
would one think through this.
If you look at c to
the n, remember we
have this inequality
from infinite time
ago that as long as x is bigger
than or equal to minus 1,
then I get 1 plus x to
the n is bigger than 1
plus n times x for
all natural numbers n.
So that means c to the n, which
is equal to 1 plus c minus 1
to the n-- so this is my x--
is bigger than or
equal to 1 plus n times
c minus 1, which is bigger than
or equal to n times c minus 1.
You see?
So if I want to make this big,
it suffices to make this big.
So that's what I'll do.
So let n be a natural
number such that n is
bigger than B over c minus 1.
Then now this we did off
to the side we'll just
put in the proof now.
And c to the n equals 1
plus 1 minus c to the n
is bigger than or
equal to 1 plus n times
c minus 1, which is bigger
than or equal to n times
than B over c minus 1 times c
minus 1 equals B. So now
let's prove the first claim,
that if c is between 0
and 1, then the limit as n
goes to infinity of
c to the n equals 0.
So first, I want to prove
the following claim--
that we, in fact, have a
decreasing sequence, which
is bounded below by 0.
So claim for all n, 0
is less than c to the n
is less than, I should say, c
to the n plus 1 is less than c
to the n.
So the proof of this claim is a
very simple induction argument,
so we'll do this by induction.
So we have the base
case n equals 1.
So we are assuming that
c is between 0 and 1.
And if I multiply
through by c, I
conclude that 0 is less than
c squared is less than c.
And that's the n equals 1 case.
And the inductive step is
essentially the same proof.
Suppose 0 is less than c to
the m plus 1 is less than c
to the m.
Then multiplying through by c,
we get that 0 is less than c
to the m plus 2 is
less than c to the m
plus 1, which is
n equals m plus 1.
Here, we're using
this fact here--
that c is positive so it
doesn't flip the inequalities,
so I can multiply it through
and preserve the inequalities.
So this shows that this
sequence is monotone decreasing
and it's bounded below by
0, and in fact bounded,
because c to the n and absolute
value, these are all positive,
is equal to c to the n.
And c to the n is less
than c to the n minus 1,
which is less than c to the
n minus 2, so on, and so on,
which is less than c.
So it's bounded.
I guess I could have built
that into this inequality
and proved that as
well, but that's OK.
So it has a limit.
So by the previous theorem, has
a limit, and I'll call it L.
And now what I want to
show is that L is 0.
And how we'll do that is one of
these analysis tricks, where--
not really tricks-- but
rather than show with L
is directly equal
to 0, we'll show
that the absolute value
of L is less than epsilon
for every epsilon
positive, and therefore
it has to be 0 because
it's just a fixed number.
So let epsilon be positive.
Again, we're going to show that
the absolute value of L, which
is just a fixed number,
is less than epsilon.
And therefore,
capital L has to be 0.
Then there exists, since this
sequence converges, an M,
a natural number, such
that for all n bigger
than or equal to capital
M, c to the n minus L
is less than 1 minus c
times epsilon over 2.
Now, maybe you're wondering why
didn't I just use epsilon here?
Well, in the end,
it's just going
to come out to this being less
than epsilon in absolute value.
Otherwise, I would have come
out with less than epsilon times
some number, and I did
away with that number
by choosing a
different number here.
So now we compute that
if I look at 1 minus c
times the absolute
value of L, this
is equal to L minus
c times L. And this
is less than or equal to L
minus c to the capital M plus--
let's put a plus 1, plus c to
the M plus 1 minus c to the L.
And by the triangle
inequality, this
is less than or equal to L
minus c to the M plus 1 plus--
now c to the M plus
1 minus c to the L,
so I can pull out a c which
is positive, so I can get L.
Now, M plus 1 is
bigger than M. So it
satisfies this inequality,
and so does this one.
And therefore, this is less
than epsilon over 2 times
1 minus c plus c times epsilon
over 2 times 1 minus c.
And C is less than 1,
so this whole thing
is less than
epsilon over 2 times
1 minus c plus another
epsilon over 2.
So I get epsilon over
2 times 1 minus c.
And thus, the absolute value
of L is less than epsilon.
And since epsilon was
arbitrary, that implies
the absolute value of L is equal
to 0, i.e., L is equal to 0.
So that's a very
concrete application
of some of these theorems we've
been proving, which is really--
I think the only real
reason one proves
theorems is you typically have
a concrete example of something
in mind that you want to study.
But in order to
study it, it often
requires some general
machinery, i.e., theorems.
So now we'll talk a
little bit about sequences
obtained from other sequences.
So these are called
subsequences,
or sequences obtained
from a single sequence.
So what do I mean by this?
Let me give you the
precise definition.
So we started off with a
sequence and an increasing
sequence of integers, n sub k.
So let me just say what this
means rather than write out
the word and then
say what it means.
So this is the sequence
of natural numbers, which
are strictly increasing.
n sub 1 is less
than n sub 2 is less
than n sub 3, and so on.
The new sequence, x sub n sub
k-- so now the index is not n,
but the index is k--
is called a subsequence of
the original sequence x sub n.
So how should you view
subsequences of a sequence?
You should think that I line
up all the entries of x,
of my original sequence
x sub n, and then
I just start picking
entries out of the sequence.
But every time I make a choice,
I have to move to the right
and make another choice.
That's what I was just saying
there, expresses this condition
that this sequence of natural
numbers is increasing.
So I pick an entry
in the sequence.
That's going to be my first
guy, the first element
of my new subsequence.
And then I move to the right,
and maybe I pick the next one,
maybe I pick one three down.
I pick that one.
And then I move to the right
of that one and pick a new one.
And then I move to the right of
that one and pick another one.
So if you want to
generate a subsequence
from an original sequence,
how do you think about this?
Again, line them all up,
start picking entries,
but every time
you pick an entry,
you have to move to the right in
order to pick your next entry.
So let me give you some
examples and non-examples.
So for example, if our original
sequence is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
and so on, what would be
examples of some subsequences?
The odd numbers 1,
3, 5, 7, 9 and so on.
You see how I'm taking
the original sequence,
so this is x sub n.
I'm just picking entries
from the original sequence,
but every time I pick an
entry, I move to the right
and pick a new one.
So I picked 1, now I
get to choose anything
to the right of that.
I pick 3, now I can choose
anything to the right of that.
So in the language
of this definition,
the increasing
sequence of integers
is just the odd
integers, so 2k minus 1.
So here, x sub n
is equal to just n.
I could pick another
subsequence would be
the sequence of even numbers--
2, 4, 6, 8, 10.
This is a subsequence of
this original sequence.
Here, the increasing
sequence of integers is 2k.
I could pick the
subsequence could be
the sequence of prime numbers--
2, 3, 5, 7, 11, 13.
And the increasing--
so I don't have
a general formula for that.
Good luck finding
one, but we'll just
write this as k-th prime number.
Now, what would
not be an example?
So these are examples
of subsequences.
Not examples of
subsequences would
be, for example, the
sequence 1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
This is not a subsequence
of this original sequence.
Remember, I have a
sequence of natural numbers
which is increasing.
And x sub n sub k means
that this new sequence is
obtained from the old
one by picking entries--
by picking an entry,
moving to the right,
picking the next entry,
and picking the next entry.
Here, in order to get this
sequence from this one,
I just stay on the first
entry and keep picking it.
But that's not how a
subsequence is defined.
So here, if you like, this would
mean n sub k is equal to 1.
And this is not a strictly
increasing sequence
of natural numbers.
Or 1, 1 3, 3, 5, 5, and
so on-- that's also not.
So these are not subsequences
of the original sequence
given here.
So I hope that's clear.
Now, I want to emphasize this--
I'm not saying that the
number you pick each time
has to be different from the
number you picked before,
meaning the value.
You couldn't have 1, 1, 1, 1
as a subsequence of this guy
because 1 is only
in the first entry.
You can't keep
picking one entry.
You have to pick
an entry and move
to the next entry or
the one after that
and pick that entry to
obtain your sequence.
But that doesn't
necessarily mean
that those actual
numbers in those entries
have to be different.
So for example, if I look
at the sequence minus 1,
1, 1, minus 1, 1, one meaning
x sub n is equal to minus 1
to the n-th then a perfectly
good subsequence is given
by minus 1, minus
1, minus 1, minus 1,
where it looks like I'm just
picking one of the entries,
but really I'm not.
Here, the increasing
sequence-- so
what I'm doing here to
get this new sequence,
I picked the first entry,
then I picked the third,
then I picked the fifth,
then I picked the seventh.
So n sub k equals 2k minus 1.
So all the actual numbers
appearing in the sequence
are the same, but I'm actually
picking different entries
from the original sequence,
where they appear.
So this is also fine.
So is 1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
This is n k equals 2 times k.
So these are all
good subsequences.
So these were subsequences
of the original sequence.
These are subsequences
of this sequence.
So from a given sequence,
we can obtain new sequences
from this original
sequence in this way.
So a natural question
is to ask, how
does going from a
sequence to a subsequence
behave with respect to limits?
If the original sequence
converges to a limit,
does a subsequence or
does every subsequence
converge to that limit as well?
And this shouldn't come as
a surprise that it does.
Because all of the elements of
the sequence are getting close,
all the entries of the
sequence are getting
close to a given number.
And a subsequence is just, if
you like, picking certain ones
along the way.
So certainly if I'm
in a subsequence,
then as long as I'm far
enough out in the subsequence,
I'll be close to
that limit as well.
So if you didn't get
all that rambling,
I'll go ahead and state
the theorem and prove it.
x n is a sequence
which converges to x.
And x sub n sub k is a
subsequence of x sub n.
Then the subsequence
converges to x, as well.
Limit as k goes to infinity
of x sub n sub k equals x.
So let me just start off by
making a simple observation
based on the fact that
this increasing sequence--
that the n sub k's
are an increasing
sequence of natural numbers.
Since n sub 1 is bigger than
or equal to 1 is less than n
sub 2 is less than
n sub 3 and so on,
this implies that for
all k, a natural number,
n sub k is bigger
than or equal to k.
So this is not so hard to
believe because n sub 1 has
to be at least bigger than 1.
And n sub 2 has to be at
least bigger than n sub 1,
so it's either n sub
1 plus 1 or bigger.
And therefore, by a
simple induction argument,
which I'll leave to
you, you can prove
that for all k,
a natural number,
n sub k is bigger than or
equal to k, induct on k.
So we want to prove that
this sequence converges to x.
And we're going to do that
using the only means we have.
So this is just some arbitrary
subsequence of x sub n.
All we have is the
definition to use.
So we're going to
now prove this.
So we have to show
for all epsilon
positive, blah, blah, blah, so
the first thing we have to do
is let epsilon be positive.
Now we'll use the fact that
x sub n converges to x.
So x sub n converges to x.
There exists a natural
number M0 such that
for all n bigger than
or equal to M0, x
sub n minus x absolute
value is less than epsilon.
This M sub 0 we'll choose
for our subsequence.
Choose M to equal
M sub 0, so now we
need to show that this capital
M works for our subsequence,
meaning if k is bigger
than or equal to capital M,
then x sub n sub k minus x
is an absolute value less
than epsilon.
But this just follows
from this fact.
And if k is bigger than or
equal to M, this implies,
by this inequality, n
sub k is bigger than
or equal to M, which
remember, is equal to M sub 0.
So n sub k is some
integer, so natural number
bigger than or equal to M sub 0.
So that implies
by this inequality
that x sub n sub k minus
x in absolute value
is less than epsilon.